ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เตรียมใส่ทำนักเรียน
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้กลับมา
ตอบมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเพียวตีแล้วก็ณห้อง
เรียมยั่วกัน Hey  Yeah  5 อยากเรียนหรือ
ยังครับอ่า
อยากเรียนแล้วค่ะค่ะเกรียนแล้ววันนี้เรา
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับอ่า
เรียนภาษาไทยงานวันนี้วันที่ 3 ใช่ไหม
ครับว้าวอันนี้วัน 3 วันที่ 3 เป็นวัน
อะไรครับ
เป็นวันพุธ 5 วันที่ 3 เป็นวันพุธนี้นี่
วันพุธที่ 3 เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนหน้าเดือนนี้เดือนพฤศจิกายนแล้ว
ปีสองปี
นี้คศอะไรครับปีคศ
2000  21 ปีคศ 2000  21 ว้าวแล้วปีพต
อะไรครับ E ผช
2564  5 ปีพศ
2564 มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันเย้แล้วเรียนภาษา
ไทยกันตอนนี้ตอนนี้ที่เราเรียนกันกี่โมง
แล้วครับ
น่ากี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
10:50 น
10:50 นนาทีนะอ่ามาเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
เดี๋ยวเควันนี้ค่ะวันนี้วันนี้อ่าเพียง
ตี้และน้องเรียมจะพานักเรียนไปเที่ยวไป
เที่ยวอาเย้ไปให้กันหน้าแล้วเราจะไป
เที่ยวที่ไหนคะอ้าเราจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ครับนี่เราจะไปเที่ยวที่
ที่สวนสัตว์
r50 นสัณที่สวนสัตว์มีสัตว์อาจสารอายุ
ที่สวนสัตว์อ่ะวันนี้มีใครมีใครไปสวน
สัตว์กับเพียร์ตี้มีใครไปสวนสัตว์กับน้อง
เรียมอีกครับมีใครไปอีกครับน้าแล้วก็
เรียนมาไปสวนสัตว์ที่อาตีกะห์เปรี่ยมนะคะ
นักเรียนก็ไปสวนสัตว์ด้วยกันกับน้องเรียม
กับเทียบที่กับนักเรียนก็ไปสวนสัตว์โบ้ไป
สวนสัตว์ทุกมีคนหน้า
แล้วในรูปที่เรียมเห็นอ่าในรูปนี้อ่า
มีคนไทยคนห้ามีคน 4 คนว้าวมีคน 4 คนในรูป
นี้มีใครบ้างครับ
หน้ามีใครมีขอเรียนจำได้อ่ะจำได้จำจำใคร
ครับ
ดำแม่อ๋อจำแม่ไส้ไหมอ่ะแม่คุณแม่นี่คนนี้
เป็นแม่
ครับเราเรียมก็จำ
ลูกสาวอาจำลูกสาวได้พี่อาร์ตี้จำจำลูกสาว
ได้นะพี่อาร์ตี้ก็จำคุณแม่ได้หน้าจะ
เอาวันนี้มีคุณพ่ออาคุณพ่อ a คุณพ่อใคร
ครับคุณพ่อ
เป็นผู้ชายอ๋ออ๋อคุณพ่อเป็นผู้ชายคนนี้
นี้ดี
วันนี้เป็นคุณพ่อ
เป็นพ่อ
เรื่องข้อ
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นพ่อซึ่งคนนี้เป็น
เป็นลูก 5 ลูกผู้หญิงหารูปผู้หญิงเป็นลูก
สาวลูกสาว
สาว
นะครับอ่านแล้วคนนี้ล่ะครับ
รูปผู้ชายอ้าเป็นลูกชายเป็นรูปเป็นลูกผู้
ชาย
ลูกผู้ชายเรียบเขาเรียกลูกชายอ๋อโอเคค่ะ
ลูกผู้หญิง
เรียกลูกสาว
ค่ะเอ้วันนี้วันนี้มีลูกชาย
ลูกสาว
อา
ลูกชายครับแล้วก็มีหน้ามีพ่อ
มาสวนสัตว์มีแม่มาสวนสัตว์หน้ามีลูกชายมา
สวนสัตว์โอ้ยค่ะแล้วก็ลูกสาวก็มาสวนสัตว์
หน้า 5 ชายครับอ่าครัวตี้ก็มาสวนสัตว์ฮ่า
ๆน้องหรือยังก็มา
ส่วนสั้นเท่ๆ
ค่ะวันนี้วิ่งน้ำ
เดียวดื่มน้ำก่อนอ่ะเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้ดื่ม
น้ำด้วย
เฮียตี้ชนแก้วโอเคต้นแก้ว
ชนแก้วเข้แล้วก็วันนี้พร้อมที่จะไปสวน
สัตว์หรือยังครับ
พร้อมแล้วค่ะอ้าวโอเค
อ่า
วันนี้อ่าวันนี้ที่สวนสัตว์วันนี้มีอะไร
ที่สวนสัตว์อยู่บ้างครับตอนนี้
ลูกสาวลูกสาวสาวกำลังดูอ๋ออ๋อลูกสาวกำลัง
ดูดูอะไรครับหนูขาวดูอะไรอ๋อหมีหมี
ใช่ไหมอันนี้หมีหมี
ตัวสี
สีขาวอ๋ออ๋อก็เลยเรียกเรียกหมีขาว
มีหมีขาวอยู่ที่สวนสัตว์
ในค่ะน้องเรียมครับน้องเรียมเห็นลูกสาว
ใส่เสื้อสีชมพูอ๋ออ๋อลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสี
ชมพู
หาลูกสาวชอบชอบสีชมพูชมพูครับคุณแม่คุณ
แม่ก็ใส่เสื้อสีชมพูมี
อาหาคุณแม่ก็ใส่เสื้อสีชมพู
เอเชียครับแล้วคุณพ่อแม่
โอเคครับโรงเรียนมถามครับถามว่าอะไรครับ
แล้วคุณแม่ก็ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวอ่ะ
เอาเสื้อแขนยาว
ครับ
สีเขียวค่ะอ๋อสีเขียววนี่คุณแม่ใส่เสื้อ
แขนยาวสีเขียวอ้าใช่แล้วหน้าแล้วตรวจที่
ครัวตี้ก็เห็นคุณพ่อคุณพ่อก็ใส่เสื้อแขน
ยาว
น่าคุณพ่อก็ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
แล้วคุณพ่อใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีอะไรคะอ้าคุณ
พ่อใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีอะไรครับฮ่าๆๆกวนขอ
ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีอะไรสี
ฟ้าไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โอเคคุณพ่อใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีฟ้าหรือสี
น้ำเงินครับอ่ะ
ถ้ามีอะไรคะนักเรียน
เบี้ยตี้ Theater พี่คิดว่าคุณพ่อใส่
เสื้อแขนยาวสี
น้ำเงิน
หมอเงินไหมเป็นน้ำหนึ่ง
หรือสีน้ำเงิน
สีฟ้าจะ 4
อ่อนถ้าสีน้ำตาล 4 เข้มด้ายสีน้ำเงินสี
เข้มกว่าโอเคอ่ะไม่เป็นไรอะพี่อาร์ตี้ให้
คุณพ่อใส่เสื้อสีน้ำเงิน
หน้าโอเคค่ะเสื้อแขนยาว
เสื้อแขนยาวสีน้ำเงิน
อ้าโอเคพี่อาร์ตี้พี่อ่ะดิเห็นเห็นลูกชาย
ลูกชายก็ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
น่ารู้ลูกชายก็ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
มี
ห่าอะไรค่ะยาวเหมือนเนื้อผมยาวครับของลูก
ชายเป็นสีส้มอ่าเสื้อแขนยาวของลูกชายเป็น
สีส้มชายทรายครับน้า
แล้ว 5 เปียตีเห็นเห็นคุณพ่อคุณพ่อก็ใส่
กางเกงกางเกงสี
สีส้มช่องให้อ่า
กางเกงสีส้มนะครับเค
คุณข้อใส่รองเท้า
น้ำตาลอ้าใช่ครับคุณพ่อใส่รองเท้าสีน้ำ
ตาลนี่รองเท้าสีน้ำตาลหน้า
แล้วก็มีกระเป๋ามีปรับขอดูด้วยนี่ครับ
เอ๋าคุณพ่อถือกระเป๋ากระเป๋าสีอะไรครับ
กระเป๋าสีเหลืองถ้ามีกระเป๋าสีเหลืองอ่ะ
คุณพ่อถือประเป๋าสีเหลืองโอเคสีเหลืองอ่ะ
เสื้อคุณแม่
สีเขียวใช่มั้ย
ป่าวคิดเหลืองโอเค
อ่า
อ้าตอนนี้อาจมีอะไรอีกครับมีอะไรอีกนัก
เรียนเห็นอะไรเห็นอะไรอีกครับ
น้องเรียนเหตุให้อีกต้นไม้ขอต้นไม้นี่
ต้นไม้ต้นไม้สีอะไรครับ
ต้นไม้สีเขียวอ๋อมีเริ่มต้นไม้สีเขียว
มาก
บ้ามาว้าวที่นี่ญาตินี่ค่ะเรียงอยากเข้า
ไปข้างในอยากเข้าไปแล้วป้ายเดี๋ยวเราเข้า
ไปเข้าไปข้างในเข้าไปเข้าไปข้างในสวน
สัตว์กัดหน้าเข้าไปข้างในจะเดินเข้าไปใช่
ไหมคะเดินเข้าไปใช่ครับเดินเข้าไปในสวน
สัตว์
หน้านี้ครับเข้ามาแล้วเข้ามาแล้วอ่ะ
อาจหน้าเข้ามาที่สวนสัตว์เห็นอะไรเห็น
อะไรที่สวนสัตว์บ้างครับ
ลิงโง่นี่นี่ตัวนี้ใช่ไหมครับตัวนี้ตัว
อะไรครับลิง
[เพลง]
น้ำหอมอีลิงลิงอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
ลิงอยู่บนกิ่งไม้อ่อนอี้กิ่งไม้ลิงอยู่บน
กิ่งไม้อ่าลูกสาวลูกสาว
ลูกสาวทำอะไรครับลูกสาวมองดูลิงดูลิงอ่า
ลูกชายลูกชายทำอะไรครับ
ลูกชายมองดูลิงลูกชายก็มอง
มองดูลิงเจ๊เจ๊ว้าวหาชักมีลิงอยู่กี่ตัว
ค่ะมีเลนส์ปี่ตัว R  R มีลิง
สามตัวครับลิง 123
เบอร์ 3 นี่ลิงสามตัวห้ามีลิงตัวใหญ่แล้ว
ก็ลิงตัวเล็กห่าลิงตัวเล็กลิงตัวใหญ่จ้า
ได้
นี่ตัว
แล้วคุณพ่อคุณพ่อก็กำลังอ่าน
คุณพ่อกำลังอ่านอ่านชื่อลิง
อ่าน
ได้ครับหน้าที่ให้กำลังอ่าน
ครับคุณเพราะอ่านอ่านชื่อลิง
[เพลง]
ลูกสาวก็ดีใจๆลูกสาวดีใจได้เห็นเห็นลิง 5b
ใจ
[เพลง]
อ่าโอเคๆเดี๋ยวเราดูลิงดูลิงแล้วอะเดี๋ยว
ไปดูอะไรอีกครับ
หาดู
มี
นี้นี่อันนี้ก็เป็นลิง
อานี้ก็เป็นลิงน่ะตอนนี้ตอนนี้มีลิงกี่
ตัวครับ
มีลิง 3 ตัวค่ะมีลิงสามตัวตัวนี่1ตัว2ตัว
3ตัว
อ่ะ
ลิงลิงทำอะไรอยู่ครับ
ลิงโหน
r6a เนเน่โหนตัวไหนโหร
อ๋อตัวนี้โหใช่ค่ะโหโพธิ์งงโหรใช้มือจาก
ขอกราบแล้วก็โหรนี่โหมิโขนโหนกิ่งไม้
โหนกิ่งไม้ว่าว้าวมีลิงโหนเขาไม้แล้วมี
ลิง
มีลิงนั่งอ่ะอาลิงนั่งหน้ามีลิงนั่งตัว
นี้มีตัวนี้นั่งอ้าลิงนั่งอยู่
แล้วต้องมีเดินขอมีลิงเกินอีกตัวนี้ตัว
นี้เดินออกกำลังเดิน
ตัวนี้กำลังนั่ง
หน้าส่วนตัวนี้กำลัง
โหรหนกำลังโหรลูกสาวลูกชาย
ลูกสาวลูกชายมอง
ลิงหน้ามองดูลิงแต่ตัวดีอยู่โหรหน้าตอน
นี้เขาเป็นไงครับ
ลูกชายเป็นยังไง
ว้าวยิ้มลูกสาวก็ยิ้มอ่า
ชอบลูกสาวชอบลูกชายก็ชอบชอบดูชอบดูลิง
เฮ้ยเทียบที่คะเรียงเห็นเห็นเงียบอยู่เลย
มีหางอ๋อใช่ครับลิงมีหางนี่หางอยู่ตรงนี้
นี่นี่หางลิงฮ่าก็คนนึง
ก่อนลิงงานตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้ใช้ค่ะ
ตอน
สีชมพูเป็นสีชมพูเหมือนเสื้อของลูกสาวเลย
เสื้อของลูกสาวสีชมพู
ตัวลิงก็สีชมพู
ตัวลิงตัวลิงเป็นสีอะไรครับ
ตัวลิงเป็นสีน้ำตาล
ตัวลิงเป็นสีน้ำตาลอ่ะแล้วก็มีก้นสีชมพู
ว้าว
ไปค่ะ
เห็นก้อนหิน
ก้อนหิน
เมฆก้อนหินเป็นยังไงครับก้อนหินก้อนหินสี
อะไรครับ
ก้อนหินสีเทาอ่อนหินสีเทาอ่อนอันนี้ใช่
ไหมครับอันนี้อันนี้ก้อนหิน
ใช่ค่ะกรหินสีเทาวาวมีก้อนหินอยู่ตรงนี้
น่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เห็นอ.หัวหินแล้วอ่าอีกก้อน
หินสีเทา
เดี๋ยวเราดูลิงแล้วเราจะไปดูอะไร
ดูอะไรอีกครับน้าเราจะไปดู
นี่มีอะไรอยู่ในรูปนี้
ตีหนึ่งเห็นก้อนหิน
เจียรตีเห็นก้อนหิน
คุณแม่คุณแม่ทำอะไรครับ
คุณแม่ชี้มาที่ชี้ไปชี้อะไรครับชีสเต่า
เปล่าไหนเต่าครับ
อ๋ออันนี้หรือเปล่าใช่อันนี้ไหมครับใช่
ค่ะอันนี้อ้ออันนี้เป็นเต่าอันนี้ไม่ต่อ
ไปก่อนหินเพียงตี kit  psd คิดว่าเป็น
ก้อนหินหน้าแต่ไม่ใช่ก้อนหินค่ะมีเต่ามี
ขา
มีขาอยู่ตรงนี้อ่ามีหัว
มีคะอ้ามิขา
นิดเอากำลังเข้างูเห่ากำลังทำอะไรครับ
เต่ากำลังเดินออกกำลังเดิน
เต่ากำลังเดินคุณแม่ชี้ชี้ชี้เต่าขี่เต่า
ให้ลูกสาวดู
ใช้ค่ะลูกสาวก็ดูเต๋าสาวกำลังกำลังสงสัย
เต่าอยู่ไหนเหมือนพี่แอ๊ดดี้เลยพี่
อาร์ตี้ก็ไม่เห็นเต่า
คุณแม่บอกอยู่นี่อยู่นี่คุณแม่ชี้ไปนี่
เปล่าอยู่ก็มีพี่ลูกสาวก็ฟองหาเต่าอยู่
ไหนอยู่ไหนอยู่ไหน
หาอาแต่ตอนนี้ลูกสาวเห็นแล้วเห็นเต่าแล้ว
พี่อาร์ตี้อาร์ตี้ก็ก็เห็นแล้วเห็นเต้า
แล้วเขาว่าเป่ากับก้อนหินใต้
คล้ายกันหน้าคล้ายกันมิสีเหมือนกันนะคะสี
น้ำตาลเหมือนกันนะหน้าเค
ว้าวอีเต่าลูกครับเรียนเห็น
ครับเห็นอะไรอีกครับน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรอีก
ครับ
ขอนไม้อ่อนไม้
ตีเห็นมีต้นไม้
เยอะตีเห็นต้นไม้แต่พี่อาร์ตี้ไม่เห็นขอน
ไม้คอนไม้อยู่ไหนครับ
ฮิไม้ไม้คอนไม้ขอนไม้อ๋อ
อันนี้คืออะไรครับ
ขอนไม้นี้คือขอนไม้คอนไม้ไม่มีใบไม้อะนี้
เป็นใบไม้สีเขียว
คอนไม้ไม่มีใบไม้
ไม่มีใบไม้ที่ข่อนไม้ใช่ไหมครับ
ไม่มีค่ะอ่า
ไม่มีใบมาไม่มีใบไม้ไม่มี
อาหาแกเพียงติรู้แล้วเบียร์ที่เห็นจะมี
ขอนไม้อยู่โรงนี้หน้าค้อนไม้ค้อนไม้ที่
ขอนคะโอ้มีขอนไม้กี่ครครับนักเรียน
125 มิครไม้สองขอนหน้ามีขอนไม้ 2 ขอน
อยู่โรงนี้โว้โอโอ้
ว้าวๆๆอ้าวันนี้เป็นยังไงบ้างครับสนุกไหม
ได้มาเที่ยวสวนอาจอ่ะเที่ยวที่เราจะไปดู
สัตว์อะไรอีกคะอ้าวันนี้เราไม่ไปดูสัตว์
แล้วเราเหนื่อยแล้วเหนื่อยแล้วจ้าได้วัน
นี้เราดูลิงไหมดูลิงแล้วก็ดูเต่ามีเต่านะ
ครับอุ้ยหมีขาวมีหมีขาวด้วยนะครับอ่าวัน
นี้มาเที่ยวสวนศาศนามาดูลิงดูต่าวดูหมี
ขาวกันนะครับอ่าโอเคแล้วเดี๋ยวล้างหน้า
เอาน่าพี่อาร์ตี้กับผู้เรียนจะพาไปดูอะไร
อ้าเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าจอหาเขาหน้าแล้วก็มาดู
กันว่าเกียตีกับน้องเรียนจะพานักเรียนไป
ที่ไหน
เย้ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยววันนี้จ้าพี่กับน้อง
เตรียม
อ่ะบ๊ายบายนักเรียนก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวกลับมา
เจอกันใหม่คราวหน้า
ใช่ค่ะขอบคุณมากนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้ทำน้อง
เรียมสวัสดีครับสวัสดีนักเรียนรู้สวัสดี
ครับ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบาย
ม.ค